[Musique]
le rendez vous de l'école est un pilier
de la société quand l'école s'arrête
beaucoup vacille et c'est le principal
vecteur d'intégration républicaine elle
doit offrir à tous quel que soit son
origine sociale quel que soit le
territoire des conditions de son
l'émancipation intellectuelle
finalement émancipation tremplin vers la
vie de citoyen mais aussi
l'apprentissage du vivre ensemble
[Musique]
les enquêtes d'opinion que nous avons
mené pour préparer ce colloque
permettent de constater qu'une simple
question consacrés au fonctionnement de
l'école peut entraîner des écarts
d'appréciation significatif de point de
vue du descendeur de 20 points par
exemple entre les enseignants la façon
dont ils perçoivent l'école et le grand
public
il faut sarc sur l'ensemble du sondage
les résultats sont meilleurs auprès des
parents et auprès de ceux qui ont un
enfant scolarisé en rep ou en raid plus
ou un enseignant en rep ou en raid plus
c'est toujours égale tout n'est pas
aussi négatif que qu'on peut dire sur
notre système d'éducation la france est
dans la moyenne des pays de l'osce et
des votes dans nos études
internationales de type pisa mais le
niveau des inégalités scolaires et
sociales est toujours très élevé en
france c'est à dire quand on vient d'un
milieu défavorisé on a moins de chances
de réussir dans les études pisa 15 ans
mais c'est pas uniquement la seule
conséquence on a moins de chances d'être
scolarisés dans l'enseignement supérieur
en a moins de chance d'être dans les
filières prestigieuses
on a plus de chances d'aller d'en
définir professionnel on a des
difficultés d'insertion donc aujourd'hui
l'enjeu du système d'éducation c'est
lutter contre les inégalités sociales et
scolaires et sur l'échec scolaire
il faut que chaque professeur chaque
enseignant puisse avoir une liberté
pédagogique pour s'adapter au public il
a pour s'adapter aux élèves qu'il a en
face de lui et lorsqu'on a une aide aux
devoirs bien entendu on identifie les
failles de chaque élève pour avoir une
réponse adaptée et la solution allait
forcément là pour rompre avec cette
école très inégalitaire il faut
véritablement qu on acte sur chaque
élève chaque élève doit avancer
peut-être à une vitesse différente et
c'est pas dans ce carcan dans cette
verticalité de l'enseignement qu'on va
pouvoir aider chaque élève
des lits une femme
constitue une égalité insuffisamment
guérie lalliot battre elle qui n'est pas
suffisamment prise en charge
d'enseignement et je crois que cette
faille dans la réalité en partie
volontairement ignorée et il me semble
qu'il va avancer que c'est la chance d
maîtrise réelle précise et rigoureuse de
notre lent voilà une des inégalités sont
des rentes à athis mail il était
fondamental qui détermine toutes les
autres y ont leur vous que l'on retrouve
le changer à l'entrée et à la sortie de
la scolarité pour la plus basse chez les
mammifères qui maîtrisent pas le
français qui mène qu'il me dise pas non
plus en terminale l et je constate pour
marat sade et chez tous les gens
honnêtes pays très particulier où
quelques-uns des meilleurs d'une
génération dans notre histoire devenait
professeurs après tout raymond arouri
georges pompidou on était professeur
dans le secondaire en lycée avant de
connaître des carrières qu'ils ont pu le
connaître c'est malheureusement une
spécificité qui s'estompe parce que ce
métier moins attractif je crois qu'il
faut aussi que ce métier sur phase avec
la nouvelle génération qui n'attend plus
obligatoire remords un salaire à
l'ancienneté une mobilité à l'ancienneté
les jeunes professeurs sont des jeunes
d'aujourd'hui il faut savoir mieux les
payer falloir ouvrir des perspectives de
carrière il faut dialoguer avec eux au
plus près en un système lourd qu'il faut
certainement aéré déconcentrer
il est absolument nécessaire de redonner
une sorte de de dignité à tous les
points de vue et d'abord d'abord dignité
financière au personnel c'est pas
possible de tenir à la fois ce langage
en disant vous êtes les plus importants
et on vous méprise parce que un des
critères aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on
gagne donc dans cinq ans dans dix ans
qui va choisir ses métiers